Gabe's in California I'm curious as to
why you condemn the use of credit cards
for everyone in every situation it's
kind of like I condemn the use of a
cigarette cigarettes don't kill
everybody that smokes them but they are
good for no one that smokes them that's
why I'm 37 years old I make 90,000 a
year I'm on baby step six and my credit
score is 815 I have four credit cards
four of which I use regularly based on
which one gives me the best rewards in
particular places I pay the bill in full
at least monthly or every car why
shouldn't responsible individuals such
as myself use credit cards because
you're not you're delusional
you are more responsible than the
average cat I'll give you that but
90,000 bucks here doesn't make you rich
and those points I've met with thousands
and thousands of millionaires I never
met a single millionaire said to have
you know made all my money with my
airline miles
Dave I got I got 1% back on Discover
let's do the math on that for a minute
okay you run a hundred thousand dollars
worth of expenditures through your
Discover card you know what you get a
thousand dollars you don't explain to me
how that's a wealth building method
that's dumber than a rock well I'm
spending the money anyway yeah no but
all of the studies tell us that the lack
of friction the lack of emotional
friction causes you to spend more when
you use plastic than when you spend cash
so Gabe you can do whatever you want but
you're judgmental but little email I can
read between the lines you Pharisee you
go do whatever you want to do dude but
millions and millions of people have
said I've had enough of credit card so
they have not been a blessing to me
they've been a curse you spend more when
you use them you spend 12 to 18 percent
more when you use plastic than when you
use cash on the typical purchase if you
go to a vending machine it's a hundred
and seventy eight percent increase in
sales for plastic users versus someone
actually puts a dollar into the little
dollar eater when you go into a
fast-food setting
Quick Serve restaurants for my friends
in the business a fast food setting you
roll into Mickey D's you spent an
average of 37 percent more when you use
plastic then cash in cash buyers do
because when you lay cash up on the
counter you emotionally go ouch I just
spent money and something leaves your
possession in return you get something
back like a hamburger have you ever
thought about the fact that Rachael Cruz
brings us up when you put your credit
card on the counter they give it back to
you and your hamburger there was no
visual trading going on here if you
trade something for something you
recognize that a transaction has
occurred but where you give them
something they give it back to you and
they give you their stuff no visual
transaction has occurred now I know
that's primitive game and you think
you're above these primitive things but
you're not
these are behavior processes and
personal finances 80 percent behavior
it's only 20% head knowledge now you're
probably not gonna go bankrupt because
you're conservative and you're
legalistic and everything else and
you've got your little financial plan
figured out so go do your plan dude it's
fine I'm finally if you go do whatever
you want to do but I am 100% sure after
having worked with millions and millions
and millions and millions of families
over the last 30 years
five million families of gone through
Financial Peace University we've sold 15
million books 16 million people listen
to the show now what does that say it
says credit card is not working and I
think we're gonna look back in a decade
or so and look at the credit you
remember when you were a kid any of you
old like me your kid ever buy smoked and
then they decided it wasn't healthy so
they had smoking sections in restaurants
remember that and as if the smoke didn't
leave the smoking section and go over to
the other section it was the dumbest
thing they had smoking sections on
airplanes I'm old enough to remember
that and before that you could just
smoke on an airplane it's like a tube
full of smoke
with wings but gradually society went
from the 1950s or 40's with Clark Gable
or whoever with a cigarette hanging out
of his lip in every movie or Frank
Sinatra whoever the cigarette hanging
out their lip in every movie because
that made you cool it went to where the
cigarette isn't cool anymore
it's just trashy because people die from
it and it's pretty much nobody likes it
anymore Society has kind of looked up
and goes cigarettes kill you they're
stupid why no why would you smoke now
people do still smoking if you smoke I
don't care I'm not mad at you don't
listen to rumors you didn't look smokers
honest I just don't seem there's society
has turned on you because Society has
recognized that smoking is stupid and it
kills you and so if you're in the
tobacco business your business is almost
gone during my lifetime it was a massive
multi-billion dollar thing when I was a
kid and it's dried up to almost nothing
now the credit card is the cigarette of
the financial world there's no upside it
kills you
when you can have a debit card that does
everything a credit card does and you're
not a higher chasing discover points
thinking that's gonna make you rich
which really makes you look
mathematically stupid so Gabe that's my
wife I've never met anybody that built
wealth because of a credit card and I've
seen people lose marriages lives
businesses and everything else because
of credit cards because of their misuse
of them and so I think they're stupid
especially with the debit cards we'll do
every single thing has the exact same
thought protections that your credit
card has the exact same proper faction
your credit card out
there's just no use for the dumb things
unless you get some frost on your
windshield won't scrape it off that's
about the only thing I could think of
this is the Dave Ramsey shape